getting out on
[Music]
you now
when a fugitive does not want to go to
jail would they jump yes I've had
several fusions that literally jumped
off buildings hi my name is Rasheen
Peppers I'm a former police captain with
the city of Newark 10 years of my career
I was detailed to the United States
Marshals service tracking down what they
consider the world's most violent
fugitives today we'll be looking at
fugitive chases and movies and TVs and
see just how real they are
let's go
90 of that is just unrealist they're
transported her without a cage in a car
that's against protocol the cage in the
car is a partition that separates the
prisoner from the officers that are
driving this protects them in the event
the person does free themselves they are
unable to get to the police officers in
the front and this scene where her being
handcuffed to the front that's against
protocol your handcuffed to the back
because they transported her with to the
front she was able to get to their
tasers if an officer rides in the rear
they ride with their firearm away from
the prisoner so they would never sit a
prison to their right if their weapon
was on the right
being transported in the middle of the
Convoy this cannon can happen if there
is some type of intelligence that this
person want is extremely dangerous two
that there are going to be others that
will be be attempting to free this
person if you have information like that
yes but we will never use marked police
cars we only transport and unmarked cars
I rate this one a two nothing else in
this clip was realistic at all
[Music]
so although Walter in this scene was not
a fugitive yet it's realistic to bait a
fugitive if feasible one we actually
sent out probably close to 100 fugitives
we had a melling list go out about them
winning these prizes we had them all
come to Atlantic City to the convention
center when they checked in there was a
false wall that you have all the agents
behind then once everything was done
doors locked and then you have SWAT
teams come in and they just start
securing everybody so yes it happens
whoa come on out Walt having a witness
there I would never have them at a seam
our main goal is to protect the public
so if you have a citizen or witness that
is helping you you never want to expose
them right and you wouldn't have two
agents
there to do a operation like that
because it's high risk they also
responded to a deserted area which is
not going to happen unless it was
something that was unplanned
stop
place your fingers behind your head
walk backwards to me
get on your knees
by having them turn around with their
hands in the air and come towards you is
the right protocol when he ordered him
to turn around they call that a felony
type of apprehension because the person
may cause some type of threat or high
risk however the preferable way is not
to really keep him on his knees with his
hands up because if he drops his hands
you can't see them anymore and now you
have a situation that he has a firearm
in his hand so many of the officers have
them in prone positions with their hands
out to their sides and their palms
facing up I give it a six for this scene
[Music]
see right here a car hit a motorcycle
and the officers are still chasing born
that's just not real it's Paramount to
make sure that the person that was hit
on a motorcycle is okay and if the
person that you push needs any medical
treatment you already Owen that the
perpetrator is still on foot not
continue the Chase born at this point
[Music]
yeah it was realistic the offices were
in a foot chase they don't have access
to a boat at that time so it appeared
that they were waving to see if they can
get the captain's attention let the
captain know there's someone that jumped
onto your boat however what should have
been done in the interim was that they
would need to call whoever governs their
water to advise them to stop the boat
[Music]
after he got off the boat there was
pretty much no eye contact so at that
point they should have been calling out
trying to set a perimeter it happens to
us not often but enough that you find
fugitives that are very athletic very
agile that are able to avoid
apprehension I remember we had a guy he
jumps right off the roof he falls onto a
iron cast fence he literally takes his
arm out and he runs I rated this one and
eight
[Music]
that scene is very realistic it was
quintessential for them to use some type
of aerial support normally we know when
we need a helicopter is when we plan
things by gathering intelligence knowing
the terrain and include a helicopter if
we need it this right here was something
that they were not expecting but what's
not shown in the clip is that this guy
and he's probably
hours ahead of them so when the
information came in that he was spotted
in the ambulance they needed the
helicopter to at least gain ground
well there's no right or wrong in that
however when you're blocking off a
Viaduct and you're believing you're
chasing a danger of fugitive now you
have locked the citizens in there with
the perpetrator I may have stationed a
vehicle or some officers so that each
car that's coming out of Viaduct was
stopped to make sure he did not jump
into another vehicle but to completely
shut it off I would not have done that
put it right in there
have I personally chased people through
a sewer no but have I chased them
through very high and dangerous
situations yes so I would have did the
same thing the deputy have done I would
have had my team begin to check the
vehicles that doesn't mean that we would
prolong going into the sewer but at
least while that's being done we know
that the vehicle is also being checked
as well
kill my wife
I don't care so that reaction is true
mini fugitive trackers don't really care
if they did the crime or not only thing
we know is that a warrant has been
signed for your arrest and our job is to
bring you to that respective
jurisdiction
what the deputy did was actually
protocol he was by himself there was no
reason to engage him because he could
have caused the situation to get worse
in a real life situation had he turned
around with that gun because the command
was Put the gun down normally that would
have been a probable cause for use of
deadly force
when a fugitive does not want to go to
jail and he's cornered would they jump
yes I've had several fusions that
literally jumped off buildings he should
have got on our radio gave his location
and then they could have hopefully taken
him into custody but you know he jumped
I rate this scene eight out of ten 90
seconds let's go wait wait wait 1am
at 1pm anything goes wrong you can blame
us yeah well something will go wrong and
then you're off so they're going back
and forth and that happens local
government working with federal
government is very realistic so you have
NYPD here you have the FBI here you have
the lead detective stating what he
believes that needs to be done and FBI
has a different position different
agencies different personalities
different methodologies close the island
what island
Manhattan
arbitrarily locked down the whole island
it's not realistic that imposes on
millions and millions of people trying
to move in and out of the city it's
unjustified for terrorist attacks it may
be justified however that would never
come from an NYPD officer that would
definitely come from someone in the
federal authorities to make a
determination of that sort in this scene
they haven't even identified who the
perpetrators are so who and what are
they chasing is about finding out who
did it not locking down Manhattan
catching by five
wait is that a yes on catch them by five
this guy gives detective Davis until 5
a.m to find the perpetrators of this
crime and it's already 1am four hours is
just not enough because number one
you're talking about closing down an
island right there's going to take them
more than four hours just to close the
island down and number two a deputy
mayor does not have the authority or
possess the Acumen when it comes to law
enforcement to determine how many hours
it would take for a detective to solve a
crime when you're tracking a fugitive
everything is a case-by-case basis it
could be from one hour to five years so
that's not even ethical to give him a
time frame 21 bridges in and out of
Manhattan
shut them down stop every train that
leaves the alley and loop the Subways
cutting off Bridges is not as simple as
the movie portrays they don't even have
control over those bridges however if
you had as an officer reasonable belief
that you have a perpetrator that's on a
specific Bridge of specific train or any
type of Transportation yes you have the
authority to seize it so that you can
make the apprehension however if you're
going to get in something big and
elaborate like the scene you will have
to contact those governing authorities
to ask permission to do that I gave this
a 4 out of 10. no detective has the
authority to shut down a whole city
Barry Allen Secret Service
definitely something that does take
place personally I've received at least
12 calls from fugitives in this scene
agent call is an FBI agent tracking a
fugitive FBI they do have a fugitive
unit but the Marshall service
specializes in it and my suite at the
Stuyvesant Arms Room three one one three
you're not going to Vegas you're not in
the status and arms it's very realistic
for the agent to believe that the
fugitive was providing false information
nine times out of ten when official
calls you he's not calling you to turn
himself in he's playing checkers
he's trying to find out what you know so
he can make his next move I'll tell you
what I am short of
you're going to get caught it's a
mathematical fact when the agent tells
him it's a mathematical fact that you're
going to get caught it's statistically
the truth 93 to 95 of fugitives are
apprehended movies show that fugitives
are unlikely to be apprehended so it's
definitely much higher than what the
movies and TV shows portray you didn't
call just to apologize didn't you you
have no one else to call
he was doing exactly what I would have
done when you start to attempt to
extract information from a fugitive you
may tip off to him more what you know in
that scene he says you have no one else
to call right he said that because he's
private exhausted all of his relatives
all of his friends who don't even want
this guy next to them because what law
enforcement to our house the biggest
myth that you have in reference to
tracking and catching fugitive is that
it's not always running around jumping
in cars things that I need you there's a
lot of paperwork behind this there's a
lot of interviews that are involved 10
percent may be the jumping into cars and
running after a person I rate the scene
uh nine out of ten I've been thinking
around me laugh at something I said what
do it
see that tacit movement there would have
probably made me look at them and
suspect that they were the people I was
looking for because it was just a quick
drop of their head it was avoidance and
that would have concerned me because how
would they know me to want to avoid me a
lot of the future trackers most of them
don't know their fugitive personally
they just know them by a picture so it
is realistic that the fusion trackers
would be thrown off by Captain America's
disguise
negative
this scenario they're in a mall
definitely not the best place to do it
what I would have done was just maintain
a surveillance and when they left the
mall maybe be able to take them down in
a feasible Place give me a floor run
down negative on three
negative on two the future trackers they
broke off in pairs which is always what
you want to do you never really want to
be by yourself in the event that you
have to engage The Fugitive to spread
out in the mall that's a way of setting
a perimeter and yes when you're in a
noisy place like that it is realistic
for future trackers to wear earpieces
and then press it deeper into their ears
so they can hear the communication it's
not just a movie Trope at all excuse me
what
so when it just started kissing it may
throw a fugitive tracker off because
that's not the behavior that the future
tractor is going to be looking for many
of the future trackers are trained to
look for things that are pronounced
things that are normal because those
things become invisible to a Layman the
environment is going to dictate what
you're going to look for they just
started kissing that's a natural thing
that you will see in the mall and a
fugitive tracker is not going to think
that's abnormal however for me I would
have looked and assessed because of the
timing of the kiss it wasn't like it was
taking place when I walked onto the
escalator and saw it taking place now it
happened at the exact time as we met I
rated this one 9 out of 10. it does take
place where fugitive will produce
themselves in the open so that they can
be invisible to the actual tracker
well the disgustles are definitely
realistic the community dictates type of
disguises you can wear I've done many
disguises one that stands out to me it
was a murder that took place in
Maplewood New Jersey we received some
intelligence where a couple of
apartments that he could be in they were
experiencing some electrical problems so
I wouldn't post as an electrician one
thing that we have to be careful when
we're disguises is disguising ourselves
under actual companies here you know
he's dressed as a chicken for a company
we normally probably wouldn't want to do
that because then you put that company
at risk as well
tactically that's not how the Marshals
are actually going to enter they were a
team at the back door that was stacked
in the team at the front door stack
means they would have a line of officers
who would have different types of
instruments or tools they would have a
bunker in front of them a bunker is a
shield they would have had ballistic
helmets on they would have had other
devices to distract if you watch most of
the scene and would have limited all of
the fighting and people jumping out all
these areas because they would go in and
everything would have been tactically
sound and contained
think about it
get away the no knock is very
controversial the no knock is when we
can articulate that us knocking puts the
officer in some type of risk or the
evidence will be destroyed I would say
just for conversation purposes and no
knock would have been acceptable for
that situation they hit the door people
came they were armed that one guy tried
to go into the bedroom he ended up
getting shot because he didn't listen to
the officer and under the baby there was
an assault rifle The Dilemma is coming
in between both sides law enforcement
and the citizens the police officers
that have to go out here put their lives
on the line and also the citizens that
already have lost their life and it's
going to really have to fall on each
state or the legislators to put
something in place that's going to
satisfy both sides I rated this scene an
8 out of 10 the surveillance was very
realistic the Mayhem inside the
apartment was definitely realistic
that's what you're going to get when you
enter and department for a valley
fugitive especially in the wrong manner
correctional officers did were correct
when you're talking about six seven
prisons are running and when you look at
the offices you only had about the equal
amount so to disperse actually even to
set up a perimeter could have put the
offices in danger the best thing for
them to do at this point was to at least
maintain eye contact so that you can
radio in to get the additional resources
that you needed so in this scene they
maintained eyesight they stay behind the
mall
when the officer yells hold your fire I
actually commend him for that so the
officer chose to preserve life and
opposed to doing what probably of
officers will be quick to do
so it's no wrong or right with that
scenario but it also depends on the
office's athletic ability his strength
which it seems like you know it's hard
to do when you're carrying a big rifle
as well and trying to board a train so
they weren't able to make the train into
two prisoners got away my favorite
fugitive Chase in a movie or TV show
happens to be is a show that I was a
part of called man hunters and the
episode was called hide and seek this
apprehension was so fast-paced that my
adrenaline for at least a good two hours
just kept going thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
click on the video above